ça fait un peu l'histoire pour les nuls
c'est vrai que sarkozy et cambadélis
s'est totalement gaulois je crois que la
france marche on mélange et elle marche
bien parce que vous êtes choqués par
cette formule c'est du sarkozy dans le
texte dans de l'à peu près de la
provocation
essayez de faire le buzz autour de lui
on a retrouvé le sarkozy d'avant il nous
fait une petite rechute l'a1 mais que
comme vous il à eelv est un français de
sang mêlé il le revendique et on est
d'accord et lui donc dit mes ancêtres
sont gaulois point vous dit vous n'êtes
pas la même chose mais 207 sont mes
ancêtres et il l'était pas gaulois
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas français
et donc il y a eu un processus
d'intégration dans la société française
tout en gardant un certain nombre
d'éléments culturels je bois sûrement
plus dorée de sina que le lait france le
français moyen et je mange sûrement
beaucoup plus grec que l'ensemble de mes
compatriotes mais ça ne fait pas pour
moi de moi quelqu'un qui n'est pas
assimilé pour reprendre la formule de
nicolas sarkozy alors justement il met
en avant cette notion d'assimilation est
ce qu'il ne faut pas entendre sa sortie
en fait comme un avertissement face au
danger aujourd'hui du multiculturalisme
et face notamment à la poussée du
fondamentalisme musulman dans notre pays
on banalise
il propose un pacte de d'assimilation
sous-entendu que il y à des français
qu'ils ne seraient pas de souche
c'est exactement ce que dit le front
national il n'y a pas de divergence et
même ça le pack d'assimilation jean
marie le pen n'a jamais osé le dire dans
aucun de ses meetings et dans aucune de
ces déclarations tant qu on voit
jusqu'où on est arrivé nicolas sarkozy
pour essayer de faire venir à lui
l'électorat frontiste jeudi que tout
ceci est un danger pour la france parce
que cela met l amène à jeter les
français les uns contre les autres
est ce que vous êtes français vous
n'êtes pas français votre culture n'est
pas française s'est pas de ça qu'il faut
c'est la cohésion nationale et ensemble
affronter les problèmes quand vous nous
dites qu'en fait le front national est
débordé sur son extrême droite par
nicolas sarkozy avec cette phrase sur
nos ancêtres les gaulois pas sur cette
phrase sur les 1
ancêtres les oies sur son pacte
d'assimilation mais je crois oui que le
cours actuel de nicolas sarkozy qui est
de construire un programme commun entre
une droite extrême et une extrême droite
il est en train qui arrivait d'ailleurs
tout le monde à droite s'aligne sur lui
personne ne peut résister dans ce
domaine et vous avez vu les déclarations
depuis ce matin jean christophe
cambadélis il y a beaucoup de distance
prise par tous les autres candidats à la
primaire dans personne laissant un
terminal 1 juppé je pense à bruno le
maire sur la formule les gaulois avec
tellement caricaturale que les criminels
dans son camp les critiques et sur cette
formule mais pour le reste
pour le reste sur tous les sujets tout
le monde s'aligne sur nicolas sarkozy
juppé a sur ce terrain là une un
alignement complet il l'a dit dans
valeurs actuelles
ce week-end il a indiqué que dans les
mesures du regroupement familial ou le
reste il l'avait dit avant nicolas
sarkozy donc on ne peut pas dire bien
reparler dans la danse dont je n'entend
aucune nouvelle quand vous dites que
tout le monde y est j -pc les frères
siamois d'une même politique